salut aujourd'hui je suis dans les loges
de l'européen pas ce que je fait la
première partie de la mine l'escale et
figurez vous que dans les loges de
l'européen j'ai retrouvé nico et esteban
vous souvenez celle qui captait line
glorieuse comedy club de viry dos et il
capte aussi maintenant le spectacle de
la mine
vous êtes partout les mecs vous êtes
dans 17 tonnes game de ouf donc ce soir
je vais faire ma première partie filmée
et je vous mets les images
au niveau du personnel depuis son lit
was a cartonné à nyon hervé lève toi et
marche
les packages façon il faut pas que je
puisse dire c'est en marque blanche
évidemment autour du corps cette fois ci
elle dit moi c'est pourquoi hervé
lacazette regarde regarde cette
sensation tué sur la scène de l'européen
je dois pouvoir raconter à tout moment
que déjà tout effectué entre la vision à
les dépanner
je sais déjà que c'est solide
tu es monté sur scène ce soir donc
herbet mais pas toujours comme ça tu as
le droit de prendre une décision la
décision elle est simple c est ce que tu
veux croire l'expérience de ce soir
encore plus compliqué alors a eu
d'accord oui ou non c'est un choix et
cette carte
donc qu'est ce que tu veux comme encore
compliqué non
arrivé d'aller dit oui au départ je te
laisse pas influencer les martigues ce
soit tu récupères une d347 que tu veux
mais la re30 pas pourquoi que salir
leila ok alors tu vas t'asseoir place
avec et tout en marchant qui l'a déchiré
un marchand de la déchire en argent tu
l'as des schistes marche deux actions en
même temps et raisonnable lorsque vous
avez pris des choses différentes avec
des univers différents
j'aime bien ça si je sais déjà que je
peux encore pollution interne technique
pour ça on dit que c'était comme à
gauche on est pris très mal d'alfie tout
en majuscules ans il avertit smiley en
dehors des lignes en dehors du cadre
après j'aime de points sassi
d'intelligence et de vivacité d'esprit
c'est bien parce que j'ai besoin c'est
ça marche et en bout de ligne pour
l'instant pense que la personne qui a
écrit gêne la blonde que tu as draguer
mais je pense que cette fois ça dit
qu'avec l'état de cette maladie moindre
regret par l histoire oui croire assieds
toi merci aux foules
difficile de faire sa part et à chaque
fois je m'en fous ce coup ci je vais
vous poser la même question quoi qu'il
arrive je dirais non ce n'est pas moi
comme ça des deux va pas se mentir
honneur aux dames lisa ce que tu as
commencé par écrire j'aime les
artichauts à tout le corps c'est ce que
tu as fait s'appelle un pléonasme
mystique je vous le dis si vous pouvez
qu'un jour quelqu'un qui a la corde ps3
c'est que ces personnes là où alors que
c'est une grosse moto encore jamais de
questions à benoît qu'il a vécu dix
mille ans ce n'est pas moi est ce que tu
as comme
est-ce que tu as commencé par écrire
j'aime les artichauts à la sat est
retire un coût non ce n'est pas moi même
tête de psychopathe thomas mais dont je
me permets de vous affirmer choses se
soient fait que quelques âmes en stock
madame duval aurait lâché je crois qu'un
personnes qui manquent a vraiment écrit
j'aime les artichauts pommes à dire la
vérité maintenant je pense que c'est toi
benoît si c'est elle moi oui très fort
et assieds-toi rémois merci beaucoup au
revoir merci à tous les abonnés un visa
jamais quelqu'un fait quelque chose pour
rien avec moi c'est pour ça que tu vas
me rejoindre sur scène maintenant les
jaloux plaire essayer de retrouver dans
un premier temps je vais attaquer après
j'aime de francs le corse et avec lui
plusieurs choses après 22 points tu
prends que le premier mot dans ta tête
j'espère donner dams d'accord tu as mal
à droite ont conduit mots c'est ça
auxquelles on n'a pas trouvé son premier
mot c'est peut-être ça c'est arrivé une
fois une seule fois dans ta vie tu n'as
biométrique
alors pour retrouver sa légende ou soit
et je veux pas finir là-dessus
visa a ajouté duchaussoy
bah oui c'est vrai
on va essayer un truc trafic
j'ai vraiment besoin d'essayer quelque
chose avec toi
tu vas payer d'avancé visas à partir de
maintenant qui me répond uniquement par
oui ou par non
ok uniquement par oh bah moi ce que tu
es d'accord oui mais intéressé premier
c'est ce qui varie peu les oubliés on va
aller jusqu'au bout avec toi comme
c'était la troisième personne tu me
regarde dans les yeux on va jusqu'au
bout avec toi tu as quatre blocs en
esprit avec un prénom on se retrouve on
garde toujours dans les yeux il avoue
être fan chimiques travail oat d'accra
mon garde du rallye sur terre mer 47
autres 60 repères les vers de terre mère
des mères d'allaiter ne gère pas m'aider
tu vas continuer de discuter de la mer
devant toi et jeunes des femmes des
taxes urbaine au fur et à mesure que
gace j'ai beau ou pas d'accord quand
quand j'imagine taher n'a pas
d'effectifs portent ce dont je vis de
l'islam r j'imagine que quelqu'un avec
des yeux ça c'est bon parce que deux
victoires quelqu'un du sexe féminin
évidemment la source est bien passé john
et aileen d'un certain mais un détail
personnel presque intime je le note ici
avant le vrai que nous la présente
comment ça peut être ta mère s'il te
plaît ta mère s'appelle freestyle
tu as visualiser bien ben toi là
maintenant on s'en sort parce que moi
j'avais crise
vidéo sur youtube des figures allant du
1er janvier au 30 à raison je fais une
vidéo par jour sur youtube où j'explique
des trucs de mentalisme j'en fais une
ola ce soir tous passés au cube une
vidéo marrante
abonnez-vous à la chaîne youtube accès
de la zone merci beaucoup
oui